hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure Marvin
und willkommen aus dem grungeon Market
hier gibt es wirklich das Beste curien
street food wir sind ja auf der Reise
zusammen mit japo da und und Yang plazig
klar
kann uns schon mega viel über den Markt
sagen oh das weiß ich nicht aber ich
denke schon
also sie wird auf jeden Fall uns viel
Infos zu dem ganzen Putin geben wir sind
zu fünf das heißt wir können wirklich
alles probieren und jetzt testen wir
einfach mal ne let's go
[Musik]
unsere erste Station ist ein Früchte und
Saftladen und hier kriegt man einen Rist
Drink das ist fermentierter Reis mit
Zucker und Zimt glaube ich gemischt und
ja den kriegt man hier für 1,50 € 2000
Bonn erste Station
der fermentierte reißdrink schmeckt so
ähnlich wie ein Milky auch wenn sie
nichts miteinander zu tun haben er ist
süß herb und säuerlich sehr lecker
unter dem Herstellungsprozess steckt
eine weitere wichtige Zutat ist
koreanische Hefe die Reis trinkmischung
wird für zwei Tage fermentiert dann wird
er gekocht und mit Zucker und Zimt
abgeschmeckt und wenn man nicht ganz auf
den reisdring steht kann man sich auch
einen Smoothie mixen lassen und dafür
bekommt man einfach so ein Becher also
da sucht man sich einen aus die Früchte
die in den Becher sind bekommst du dann
auch in deinem Smoothie und das ist
jetzt hier pineapple
Melone sehr lecker ja
der erste Eindruck ist überwältigend
wenn man sowas vorher noch nie gesehen
hat wird man schnell reizüberflutet aber
auf eine positive Art lass uns jetzt
Suppe essen gehen bitte ja die Suppe ist
da na dann los ja okay super Koreaner
sind Meister in Suppe es gibt sie dort
in allen Variationen und wie man sieht
ist dieser stand besonders beliebt
vielleicht wisst ihr auch schon warum
und hier sind wir schon bei unserer
zweiten Station der Laden verkauft mando
Suppe mit Kimchi dumplings habe ich noch
nie probiert bin ich sehr gespannt drauf
sorry für alle die spätestens jetzt
einen knurrenden Magen haben hier haben
wir einmal Kimchi und hier wird alles
handgemacht vom Nudelteig bis zu den
Kimchi dumplings sobald man sich
hinsetzt servieren einem die Frauen die
man nur Suppe und man kann los schlürfen
in dieser Suppe schwimmen glückliche
Nudeln zusammen mit dem Kimchi dumplings
ein bisschen Zucchini eigenblättern und
ordentlich Pfeffer also jetzt probieren
aber Manu ist wirklich lecker
[Musik]
Zeit den dumping zu sitzen neben Kimchi
ist da auch noch mit Tofu gefüllt aber
das Rezept ist sicher ein Geheimnis
diese Nudeln sie sind al dente aber auch
gleichzeitig weiß einfach die beste
Suppe meines Lebens
[Musik]
so oder
und kommt euch der Laden bekannt vor
vielleicht habt ihr ihn ja schon mal auf
Netflix gesehen aber genug Suppe Zeit
für Pfannkuchen hey habt ihr eigentlich
schon mal von hier Poda gehört ich war
ja zusammen mit jepuda oder ihr Puder
oder oder ich kann mich dann ganz
entscheiden in Korea und jetzt möchte
ich euch meine vier top Sommer Produkte
vorstellen und da fangen wir auch gleich
mal mit den kornbaum an das ist ein
Balsam eine sogenannte Paste mit der man
perfekt sein Make-up abschmieren kann
auflösen kann und dann nimmt man sich
ein warmes Handtuch und das so ab und
dann kann man mit einem Waschgel die
Reste alle weg machen und dann hat man
wirklich double clansing ein super
sauberes Gesicht der mist-have ist wie
der Name wirklich ein Must-Have weil er
im Sommer einfach einem so einen
frisches Gefühl gibt die Haut wird
richtig befeuchtet und es bereitet die
Haut auch richtig gut darauf vor mit
Seren dann weiterzumachen und ein Serum
was ich mega gut finde ist the glow Hero
und das gibt einem gerade im Sommer auch
so ein richtig schöne
glowyhaut und jetzt kommt das Produkt
was uns in Korea das erste Mal dann
vorgestellt wurde und wir haben ihr
Bruder schon so lange danach gefragt
denn der letzte Schritt der koreanischen
Skin Carotine ist der Sonnenschutz und
dieser Sonnenschutz ist natürlich fürs
Gesicht und hat was ganz besonderes er
hat so eine leichte färbe ist dafür da
dass es nicht so weiß ist und auf der
Haut dann nicht so einen weißen
Rückstand gibt das unterschätzt man
wirklich wie wichtig der Sonnenschutz
auf der Haut ist und wenn ich euch sage
dass wir alle geklatscht haben als wir
der ZDF BFF kennengelernt haben wir
haben uns einfach mega gefreut und das
war es auch schon von mir wenn ihr die
Produkte mal alle euch in Ruhe anschauen
wollt dann findet ihr unten einen Link
da kommt ihr auf die epoderseite und mit
dem Code mal wann eine Korea bekommt ihr
immer noch 30% auf das gesamte Sortiment
und ab einem Bestellwert von 69 € noch
eine yep oder cambes back oben drauf und
jetzt viel Spaß mit dem Video und Jan
gesagt das ist die Pancakes Street also
Pancake Pancake Pancake hier bekommt man
Pancake aber nicht solche Pancakes wie
aus wie wir sie kennen also
wir sind hier der pancake-kreis wir
haben uns um diesen Pancake versammelt
weil dort hinten kann man nicht gut
stehen da sind nämlich viele Leute
deswegen probieren wir den jetzt hier ja
was was kannst du zu diesem Ferien
erzählen Reiseführerin
wow das ist
ohne ja
die mangbien oder Mungobohne wird für
diesen Pancake gemahlen und der
Geschmack hat mich ehrlich gesagt an
Reibekuchen erinnert er ist mit Gemüse
gefüllt und ist schon sehr fettig aber
unglaublich lecker wie alles hier auf
diesem Markt
dieser Markt bietet eine riesen Auswahl
aber was ich jetzt unbedingt probieren
möchte ist ganz typisches Korean street
food da wir zu fünft unterwegs sind
haben wir zum Glück noch ordentlich
Platz für die nächste Station hier
verkaufen die Tochter denn die Mama hat
schon vor 70 Jahren verkauft 70 Jahre
sind schon hier unglaublich zuerst gib
ihm
Maja heißt
[Musik]
oben da
weil es so so dick ist
das
Drogen also ein drogenkinderwagen
ja schon
und dann du liebst das hier also ich
nehme den Drogen gimbab turmke ihn in
die Soße
ja und dann das hier ist
was ist da das ist ja Sünde ist
Blutwurst also der die Origin war dann
ich kann verstehen wenn euch der Anblick
dieser glasnudel Blutwurst nicht so
anspricht aber es schmeckt wirklich
nicht schlecht die Konsistenz ist sehr
weich und ich würde mich da jetzt nicht
reinlegen wollen aber ich glaube man
kann sich da schnell dran gewöhnen
schmeckt definitiv interessant
mein Gesicht verzogen weil so viel bei
meinem Mund ist nicht so die Konsistenz
ist sehr ungewohnt weil es halt
Glasnudeln sind die zusammengepresst
sind deswegen ist es sehr weich aber es
ist nicht glitschig ja genau und
schmeckt echt sehr gut und mit dem Salz
auch schon sehr lecker
alles also es ist so typisch ist gut äh
Menu so okay als nächstes das ist Fisch
cake das gibt's auch interpokal
immer zusammen
[Musik]
es könnte sein ja habt ihr uns schon
zwei Löffel gegeben weil wir zu zweit
[Musik]
lecker okay und als letztes haben wir
ganz Klasse kennen manche vielleicht
schon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Konsistenz
zu Hause probieren wollt in Asia Stores
haben Sie die auch da und eine fertige
Soße gibt es meistens auch
du musst dich in Berlin am Görlitzer
Park hinstellen seine Jacke aufmachen
Dimbach verkaufen das macht die Frau da
ihre gimbabs sind so gut wie Drogen
genau stehst du dann neben den anderen
zum kaufen
das Team war auch sogar die Blutwurst
waren wirklich sehr sehr gut zehn von
zehn würde ich ganz klar geben und jetzt
brauche ich ein Dessert und dafür essen
wir snowflake heißt es auf Englisch es
ist Eis was wirklich so schmeckt als ob
man Schnee essen würde eigentlich das
probieren wir jetzt wir haben uns für
zwei Toppings entschieden einmal
beifußgeschmack dass es übrigens ein
Kraut und einmal Erdbeergeschmack
Erdbeeren kennen wir alle okay dann
probieren wir das Besondere bei Big so
ist es ja wie so eine Schneeflocke ja
genau
[Musik]
ja und wenn man das so rausholt dann
sieht das so trocken also so also es
wird nicht so weich innen drin dass du
irgendwann nur noch so eine Creme hast
wie bei Eiscreme aber wonach schmeckt es
ist eher so ne sahneis
en Sahne
hässlich die Sorte ist perfekt wie
findest du diese
aber gar nicht wissen ja also guck mal
das rein das ist so das bleibt in seiner
Konsistenz auch da drin wenn du es mal
rausholt bleibt es trotzdem so
flockenartig also es wird nicht zu einer
festen Masse oder verändert so seine
Konsistenz man holt es raus und es
bleibt in dieser Flocke und deswegen
schmeckt es immer wie Schnee was man ist
11 von 10 geiles Dessert absolute
Empfehlung wenn ihr mal die Chance habt
bringst du zu Essen probiert ein Dessert
reicht uns natürlich noch nicht als
allerletztes probieren wir heute Donuts
die auch schon Captain Marvel gegessen
hat der Laden ist ganz stolz darauf dass
sie diesen Laden erwähnt hat und
deswegen war da auch eine ganz lange
Schlange der ist jetzt sehr berühmt
geworden die Donuts haben wir noch ganz
warm gegessen und was soll man dazu noch
sagen mit Zucker Mehl und Fett kann man
doch nur etwas Leckeres kreieren der
zweite Donut war mit den roten
bohnenfüllung knusprig von außen und
weich von innen Schoki Jogi von innen
pasak puzzak von außen
das ist mein lieblings Donut ich bin
einfach ein riesen Fan von roten
bohnenfüllungen wie ihr im seven eleven
Video schon gesehen habt danach hat mich
der süßkartoffel-donut noch einmal aus
meinen Socken gehauen und zum Finale
hauen wir uns Hot Dog rein er ist
gefüllt mit Honig und Nüssen und
schmeckt natürlich wieder auch super
lecker das war's für heute aus dem Grand
market eine wirklich ganz besondere
Erfahrung denn so ein wuseliges treiben
aber trotzdem so eine Gemütlichkeit
dabei habe ich noch nicht gesehen oder
gefühlt oder geschmeckt das
Essensangebot ist zehn von zehn man kann
sich hier wirklich allerlei
reinverleiben und das sollte die auf
jeden Fall machen falls ihr mal in Soul
seid absolute Empfehlung hierher zu
kommen ich kann gar nicht entscheiden
was mein Lieblingsessen heute war
vielleicht die Suppe aber nein die
Kinder waren auch richtig gut waren auch
geil gut wir geben der Suppe den ersten
Platz und dann den Desserts auf jeden
Fall und den kimbabs und den
nippelbockies und alles war wirklich
massive mus
Marcel she your Ginger Masseur
das war koreanisch bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss